[Musique]
première ce que je sois des transports
tient à jour
16 personnes on est rendu à un point
vous ce que vraiment on efface en net
recul et des citoyens en quête de
réponses sur un sujet qui leur tient à
coeur avant ça vous étiez quand est-ce
qu'on vous avait parlé avec le maire de
nice
au milieu de la mêlée le député fédéral
de bertolt qui écoutent leurs doléances
à propos de la voie de contournement
ferroviaire huit ans après la tragédie
de lac-mégantic six mois comme député je
le mets pas de la pression que le projet
se fasse au dieu sauve n'aurait pas ne
répondra à cordes si si
si ce genre d'assemblée improvisé donne
parfois lieu à des échanges musclés elle
répondent quand même un besoin important
de citoyens des rencontres qu'on verra
de moins en moins si le québec perd un
député à ottawa perdre un siège pour le
québec ça signifie probablement une
perte d'un siège dans une région où l'on
retrouve les plus petites populations
mais les plus grandes circonscriptions
donc une circonscription comme mégantic
l'érable qui pourraient être touchés par
le redécoupage de la carte électorale ce
qui préoccupe les gens du coin qui
l'écoutent voight mois et l'eau c'est un
peu comme les médecins de famille non
c'est le cachera pas autant qu'il ya
d'abord un rendez vous je pensais la
même chose pour les députés nous on
empêche les autres d'un gang ça va être
quoi notre présentation tantôt la
berckoise consent alors en plus de
prendre le pouls des citoyens
les députés rencontre les élus locaux
afin de faire écho à leurs
préoccupations à ottawa avec un siège de
moins au québec la mairesse craint un
impact direct demandé un député d'avoir
des contacts avec 72 maire demanda des
députés d'avoir trois maires
lequel qu'ils travaillent le plus là les
doux si les 50 mères sont tout aussi
importants les uns que les autres mais
on n'a pas plus de temps de parole parce
qu'on a 50 municipalités
s'occuper de 50 mères éloignés les uns
des autres
ça veut dire faire beaucoup de route ces
deux choses
[Applaudissements]
le député représente la même population
qu'un élu de montréal mais sur un
territoire 500 fois plus grand le point
de chute des questions des gens quand on
parle du gouvernement fédéral mais c'est
le bureau du député si on n'est plus
capable de faire notre travail parce que
les comptes et son trop grand pour moi
c'est ce serait catastrophique
[Musique]
c'est la première fois depuis plus de 50
ans qu'une province est menacée de
perdre du poids à la chambre des
communes pendant qu'une région du québec
comme celle ci pourrait en souffrir la
colombie britannique l'ontario et
l'alberta s'apprête à gagner cinq
nouveaux sièges la croissance dans les
provinces de l'ouest a été plus forte
que la croissance au québec le québec
perd un siège en raison peut-être une
plus faible natalité en raison aussi
d'une immigration qui est plus faible si
le calcul est mathématique le débat lui
devient politique nous ce qu'on demande
à monsieur trudeau c'est de préserver le
pot en pourcentage du québec dans le
nombre de députés québécois atteints
mais pour l'instant justin trudeau
refuse de se mouiller j'entends très
clairement la préoccupation de plusieurs
canadiens dont les québécois nous allons
continuer travailler là dessus
dernier arrêt de la journée
dans une entreprise de tête froide qui
cherche à embaucher des travailleurs
étrangers temporaires pour pallier la
pénurie de la main de quelqu'un qu'on
appelle on n'a jamais la même réponse
c'est le bureau du député qui est
rapidement des mairies le tout et sans
cet appui à l'avenir dit elle son
entreprise pourrait perdre des contrats
nous on a besoin de réponses assez
rapidement seulement les agents leur
retour nous rappellent assez rapidement
le redécoupage de la carte électorale
entrera en vigueur en 2024 mais déjà le
député redoutent l'impact les gens de
son comté et si on commençait à jouer
là-dedans que l'on commence à diminuer
le nombre de députés ben c'est dommage
mais il ya des québécois qui seront
plantés je pense que le premier ministre
paul choix de maintenir le nombre de
députés du québec à 78
[Musique]
m